sherry and speaking of the outdoors we
love a fun
outdoor activity for the entire family
so let's ride the wave to cowabunga bay
rocky is there live to celebrate the day
before
national water park day hey rocky hey
you guys yeah we're getting in a day
early i'm pretty sure i have a mass tan
already
okay we're here with shane the owner but
before we start talking about how you
guys can celebrate national water park
day here at cowabunga bay
we put our intern to the test to see if
she could ride
this slide right here shane introduce us
to the slide so this is our surfing usa
slide
six lane downhill race to the finish
each one of the lane has a timer on it
oh my god you're actually timed
and then you either rank first second or
third yeah maria
and you do it with style girl that was
awesome that was so much fun and
obviously this is open to
any age group any as long as you're 48
inches or above
okay we like to hear that all right
let's talk about how everybody here
and tourists coming into town can
celebrate national water park day
tomorrow and beyond at cowabunga bay
what's going on happy we finally got an
official day recognizing water park but
with this heat it feels like every day
should be waterpark day
right i feel like cowabunga bay is
national water park every day
i feel like it too yes and i've been
that way this summer we've had a really
good crowd
oh good well i'm glad everybody's
welcome back in what are you how are you
guys celebrating what's going on this
weekend and coming up after that lots of
fun stuff
friday is our family and friends day
where we have free parking and free
sodas and all kinds of great deals on
family food
food family food not food and then
saturdays it's our epic fireworks
celebration oh my gosh so this place is
popping
in the daytime and in the evening yes
we're open late on the weekends which is
sometimes nice after the sun goes down
after five o'clock you can stay until
nine oh we love that okay and what about
for locals
do you guys have any special deals for
them our park is completely catered to
the local clients
yes okay so season passes right now are
the best deal they're on sale for half
price and we still have
you know half our season left we go till
the end of september all right
well we are celebrating national water
park day we're getting in a day early
but tomorrow is the day you guys get
your tickets come on down to cowabunga
bay
and try this out you're next right
we want to see you coming down that side
thank you so much las vegas